[Music]
[Applause]
big story of the day though had to do
with gambling in the NFL and the NFL is
investigating the Colts defensive back
Isaiah Rogers for gambling violations
David perdom is covering this sport done
a great job he covers Sports gambling
for ESPN kind enough to join us on short
notice here walk us through this David
how did we get to this point how did the
NFL how is it brought to their attention
yeah yesterday a website called Sports
handles a web website that covers the
sports gambling industry do a real good
job they broke a story that the NFL was
investigating a Colts player for what
they described as pervasive betting and
eventually when that story came out we
saw everybody started digging in we got
confirmation that it was Isaiah Rogers
um it looks like he had opened an
account an associate's name and had been
betting uh pretty significantly not
necessarily Total Money Mount
uh it was 25 to 50 bets most of them but
there were a lot of them like a hundred
of them and sources say that included
some on Colts games was he betting on
the Colts to win or lose because we
don't know that yeah we don't know that
yet so from what I understanding there
were prop bets on player statistics
on-game outcomes on everything there
were a lot of bets being placed uh was
was were any of these bets due with
injuries or anything like I'm trying to
figure out exactly what the NFL is going
to zero in obviously him gambling did he
gamble at the facility uh what happened
with Calvin Ridley and some of these
Detroit Lions players Washington
Commander player uh what what is going
to be the focus of the NFL do you
believe on this story they'll look at it
at all and I have the same questions
that you do exactly what was he using to
to place these Bets did he have any kind
of inside information where was he
placing the bets a lot of these stories
that have been popping up and this is
the eighth uh player that has been
suspended or not yet been suspended but
has been allegedly violated gambling
policy they've been caught from what
they call geolocation process right uh
State Regulators gaming Regulators have
access to a geolocation portal that when
a bed is placed it pings them and it
shows where that bed has been placed at
and if they start seeing a lot of bets
from facilities uh for the NFL college
campuses College Arenas things like that
they'll look further into it so that's
how some of the other ones have been
caught we don't know if that this is how
this one played out but uh it's one of
the ways that they do look at this stuff
I don't know if it's the right way to
look at it but somebody with the NFL
said hey it our system works we caught
him
did the NFL catch him or did somebody
else catch him and then the NFL kind of
you know is cleaning up after the
elephant in the circus well you know the
NFL has really kind of embedded itself
in the sports gaming industry they've
partnered with sports books they
partnered with State Regulators they
have a good line of communication with a
lot of the sports books so when some of
this happens and it usually is caught by
Gaming Regulators or again those
geolocation providers you know they'll
relay it to the NFL so maybe if the NFL
didn't identify it but they put itself
in positions where they would find out
quickly
what can the players uh Gamble on
legally
so they can bet on any other sport just
not professional football as long as
they're not doing it at a team facility
or on traveling with the team or with an
illegal sports book so if they use a
really good Sportsman and they want to
bet on the NBA that's fine
but see the big thing I want to know
it's like when Pete Rose told me years
ago that he bet on the Reds to win every
night well he could still manipulate the
lineup doesn't make sense that he bet on
them if he was trying to make money but
if Isaiah Rogers bet against the Colts
even if it's 50 or 100 dollars
is that a lifetime ban
you would think so uh anytime a player
has uh stepped out of line like that
it'll be a significant penalty so far
the ones that have been caught to that
have bet on the NFL it's been at least a
year suspension before they are allowed
to apply for reason statement
um so we'll have to see what the NFL
does with this one you mentioned Pete
Rose and betting a lot of people say
well if they're betting on their team
why does it matter well were they
betting the same amount every time did
they bet a little less on this game so
they didn't try maybe just hard it's
just a can of worms that I don't think
the NFL wants to open up at all uh if
you're involved in the NFL you can't bet
on the NFL it's pretty that much that
simple
and I'm wondering Calvin Ridley had one
of the baddest beats of all time David
he bet 1500 and it cost him 11 million
dollars in salary here I got what point
and I don't know what the NFL does with
seminars and maybe it's not even fair to
ask you this but are they trotting out
Calvin Ridley to talk to the rookies are
they are they doing things so these
players know and I'm giving the players
a little bit of Doubt here that maybe
they don't understand everything that
they're allowed and not allowed to do
but damn you got to grab their attention
at some point because you're going to
throw away an entire year of salary if
not more
yeah 100 NFL says it educates 17 000
employees players League Personnel
everybody every year on the sports
betting policy now the sports betting
policy changed just slightly in 2018
when we had the Supreme Court decision
that kind of started this launch of
sports betting Across the Nation uh they
did switch their policy to allow players
to bet on other sports they did add in
that Nuance though that hey you can't
bet on team facilities at Team
facilities so there are some nuance and
I can definitely understand how maybe a
player slips by if I was to be tested on
all of ESPN's internal policies I
probably would mess mess something up as
well I can't understand how you bet on
the NFL in your head in your heart you
know that's wrong you're playing in it
you're getting inside information you
know things that the public doesn't and
you're using that to bet or allowed to
bet on it that doesn't make any sense to
me and it certainly doesn't make any
sense that you'd risk million dollar
salaries to make a few bets I get it
when an athlete uses Peds that's to make
his performance better this is just hey
I'm gambling and my friends are doing it
and I'm going to do it as well what do
you think is next in this story
I think there's going to be more
mistakes made we've reported that we're
expecting another wave of sports betting
violations potential violations that the
NFL is looking in I've heard upwards of
10 to 15 even up to 20 other players of
violation so I think we're going to see
more mistakes in the coming years
there's a theory in academic Theory
where anytime an illicit activity such
as betting is introduced into a
regulated environment Society takes a
little bit to adjust people don't know
exactly what they're allowed to do and
what they aren't allowed to do and
eventually it comes to the point where
Society adjusts and these mistakes and
players will learn these mistakes will
kind of diminish a little bit so I do
think we're kind of in that adaptation
Theory uh process right now David thanks
for joining us we appreciate it we'll be
keeping an eye on you following the
story thank you that's David purdum and
uh works for the mothership covers
gambling